hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
freddy's security breach we
well i don't need to go back there we
just got the ability to summon freddy
who i forgot was out hi
do i need you right now
i don't even know what my objective is
escape the daycare did that let there be
light okay
i've done all that
so
i'm guessing that i just go do we need
to work together do i call you do you
stay there
i'm not 100 sure
hi
oh
okay hello ah
oh freddie name shirt great
that's going to be useful probably i'm
going to just hop in freddy and then
take him for a ride because i don't know
what else to do and i'm assuming that
he's going to guide me once i do the
said thing thank you hey
i know that i can't do this forever but
whatever and there's a mysterious rabbit
on the loose
don't know where
but there is
we should get moving
you can access the main atrium with your
new security patch okay
well that's exactly what i'm gonna do
but the main atrium
is
here the main atrium the main atrium no
okay
all right so the main atrium i would
assume would be in the main area over
here
but where that is
i have identified two possible exit
points okay
the main loading dock is located under
the food court on the first floor
there is also a fire escape in the third
floor prize counter
check your fast watch i will mark both
locations on your fast map it appears
that you have no fast map you should be
able to obtain one from the creator on
the center balcony
okay oh i haven't gone any i thought we
were going somewhere okay the center
balcony
the wood now
the who recycled pizza the pizza we
ordered was weird some pieces were
different sizes or didn't fit together
one slice even had different toppings
did you recycle the old pizza from the
trash i've never come to back here
unless i'm giving sort of some sort of
major discount
my son never had sleeping problems but
after spending an evening in the daycare
he refuses to sleep with the lights out
anymore he just cries and cries and then
when i do let him keep the lights on he
wets the bed that sounds like a
lose-lose situation where is the map
collect the map
but where
you said uh the main lobby something
something i'm assuming i gotta go here
hang on hold on one second there must be
something right
this is where i'm supposed to go
yes
bye freddy unless i was put to put you
in the elevator which i did not
[Music]
okay
okay well that took forever hey
please take this map
take a map
hi
you're by far the scariest thing in this
whole goddamn game
you know that sun moon guy wasn't
actually all that scary
you're terrifying i hate you i'll take
one thank you but also screw you go to
hell i love you
thank you for the map please enjoy i
will
yeah okay
well i got a map
i don't know what good that's gonna do
me but i got a map
am i able to look at the map now
oh i'm able to look at the map now okay
freddy's location not here because i was
dumb and i didn't actually do what i
needed to do
freddy's location is over there because
i'm dumb and i didn't do what i needed
to do
all right mission find the loading dock
on the first floor food court
okay
or
man this place is big
holy hell this place is huge oh my god
what is this place
well it's obviously the freddy fazbear's
megaplex
here for the party
loading dock
hi
press tab
why enter the venue the salads and sides
okay
sure don't need to tell me twice
you want me to go an event i go an event
what are you all doing over there salads
and slides i see it over there
all i gotta do is be a little stealthy
about this
they're never going to see me coming
they're never going to see me going
either
easy
watch this
oh my god oh my god wait no hold on you
didn't see nothing dumb ass
yes please thank you i must warn you
when you enter an area where you do not
have a locator map signal
okay well those security offices aren't
exactly known to be safe so i don't know
how safe i can be
also this is five nights at freddy's so
i don't know how safe i could be
why
why is that
why would that be that way
why would you be the way that that is
why would you
hi
okay well you're not that scary i guess
oh okay
wait am i dead from that tiny thing
i can punch that thing from here to
timbuktu that seems expressly illogical
that i died to that tiny thing but
whatever
fine
[Music]
okay and i'm running
running very fastly
that sounds close
slide i'm sorry slide okay weird
all right cool i slid
oh
i'm assuming i'm safe somehow well that
was useful i guess
thank you for that
i almost didn't get to do it because the
button was a little bit quirky but
whatever
what does that sound
oh it's you
oh it's the thing okay all right then
cough or dough
this is a doe vending
machine
gross
all right whatever
different maze every hour why
why
okay
this way
sure
oh oh god
why what happened who why where
what and how
who did what now
what is it i don't see it
oh okay
oh hey how are you doing okay that's not
so bad
ah
you don't see me you don't see me you
don't see me you don't see me you don't
know where i am oh the stair up is right
there
oh no
yeah whatever you're so dumb you don't
know what you're doing
you don't know what you're doing
okay bye
we'll go over here now
oh
how'd you get there
i didn't even see you getting in the
room
that's wonderful for them
but i don't even know if i have a family
i don't even know if a family is what i
have
ew
whoa whoa wow
don't even think about it
don't even think about it don't even
think about it don't even you're
thinking about you thinking about it
stop thinking about it
quit thinking stop thinking you don't
know what you do
you stop thinking now you stopped
thinking you stopped thinking no no no
no no no
okay
now we've reached a point of negotiation
i see that you have uh
noticed my handsomeness
that's not what you said
well i win
you lose
every time
what am i doing here why am i doing it
what is my objective i
have a clue get a security badge from
the kitchen office is this the kitchen
office
oh you know around
did i get it
what did i get
drink fizzy fazz hey kids do you like
fizzy fast stink you can drink every
flavor of a fizzy fast one day take the
superstar challenge grape lemonade
cherry your fast watch keeps track of
all your purchases drink them all be
first the raddest kid on your block b
you do
apparently i want some
fizzy fast whatever what it was i don't
even remember
badge in here is this what it is
yeah great
good
not helpful uh-huh oh well
don't come in here yeah that's what i
thought okay so where is this kitchen oh
that door that door there's a door over
here
oh
okay all right perfect well this is
better hey security office
oh
security badge can i have that please
very cute
what's that all about
what's that picture all about don't
freddie are you there
oh security badges allow access through
numbered security doors the player's
security level is tracked on the fast
watch
okay
i'm trapped
chica
[Music]
it looks like you can access the fazbear
online pizza delivery system through
that console oh what
how is that supposed to help chica loves
pizza
i mean you got me there all right
welcome to freddy fazbear's mega pizza
plex quick delivery virtual ordering
system congratulations you have
qualified for a free supreme upgrade
additional charges may apply let's get
started
you are now in control of one of our
highly qualified pizza making staff bots
why follow the instructions on the left
side of your screen to force the bots to
make your perfect mouth-watering pizza
what young delicious though this dough
needs some sauce
okay
sauce
oh you know maybe later maybe at another
time where's cheese
where's the cheese not meat
that's not cheese
cheese
i like cheese i guess
okay someone tells me i'm not going to
make this some delicious meat
delicious meat
non-meat
add not meat is this bad is this the
wrong meat should i not add this not
meat
okay well i guess i'm just gonna
die hi
oh you don't look at me okay sauce
oh good my door
oh good the sauce
i didn't save i'm gonna have to run
again
okay
an oven would be ideal well good thing
it's right here and i'm gonna die here
okay
[Music]
where's it gonna drop me
great
good great
good
great
i don't know what the nom meat is
but i thought that would mean like
vegetables or something but apparently
not
god take your time
delicious to ensure a safe and timely
delivery our cutting edge pizza tracker
allows you to deliver the pizza to your
own home or residents additional mileage
charges may apply
oh hitler
well that struck for you has been
delivered how would you rate your
service pick two that apply
pick two what picture what
pick two what what what am i picking two
of what do i pick the two of what are
you talking about new slot i don't know
what the slots are i can't even decide
which one is which can i go out now hey
all right oh knife oh knife safety watch
for your
hmm
interesting
where am i going no i don't know
i'm just gonna wander
oh laggy
okay well i did my job
ask for damn sure
no one can question me
what i did exit to docs
this is what i want right
oh you're still here oh oh
i forgot about that
i forgot that that was a thing that
you're still here eating your pizza
why
why level three why do you require a
level three
oh
that's weird
strange level three why always a level
three okay there's got to be a way to
make a distraction or something
something like that you know that's what
it taught me before so i'm just assuming
that's what i gotta do
unless there's some other way that i
need to go
maybe
no
not that way
somewhere over here
oh yeah this looks dangerous
oh yeah no this is fine
okay
ah the other side of the
thing
not what i need
what does this do what does this button
do
trash
it does nothing actually that's what it
do it does nothing
trap trash
okay well i'm in the trash
i'm assuming it's a trash compactor
um
you're gonna notice me if i just slunk
right by
you're gonna notice me you're not gonna
notice me why would you notice me you're
so busy
just gonna grab this collectible
okay
easy peasy
i found the loading dock ah shout out
nothing here just talk loudly garage
doors but i don't see a way to get out
ah
here
i
think so
there's a funny locked box with a badge
on it those are the loading dock
controls something is not right
someone must have changed the
permissions you are going to need a much
higher security level to get out that
way
come back to me right away
okay well this was a bunch of usefulness
uselessness less useless not useful this
okay do i have to go back the way that i
came
i mean it says glorious exit right there
but i'm assuming i can't go no matter
what so whatever oh
what's that all about
do i go this way
okay
how did you get there
are you
you lost
uh-huh
okay
oh yeah good the showers
looks like i might be able to make a
distraction there but why would i do
that oh that's not a trap oh this is not
a trap at all
definitely not
definitely not a trip
why did i get that why do i care do i
care no
question are you gonna go into the step
oh my god
can i close this can i close it why
couldn't i close it's a
skirting
it's a skirting close the skirting
oh this is fine
oh yeah this is fine
where are you where are you i don't know
where you are where am i
where am i where are you i'm nowhere i'm
in the void
i'm gone
i've disappeared off the ether
i don't know
okay
we're fine
where's this god
this area is off limits
are you
bursting through that door
okay
okay whatever could you say some new
things
no all right
that's fine
okay
i do not know if this is where i'm
supposed to be
i really don't but i'm
somewhere that looks
progressive
progressing
oh hi what the hell
oh
oh god
i got an old poster
that's just the thing that's going to
help me survive this nightmare oh
perfect
i'm sure there's lore
i'm sure
oh god hi okay
oh yeah
okay um
okay
hey why did you do it that's right
all right okay
all right
hey hey
i'm gonna go for it
okay
that's right don't
so you don't
you don't
you shouldn't don't no no no
hey
you don't know
what
oh
no
i'm not lost because i'm hiding
you didn't see a thing
my friendly security hi okay hi
well you opened that door so politely i
thought that you might actually give me
a big old hug
and you kind of did i don't know when
the last time i saved up why am i here
how did i get here i was just trying to
get out
back to freddie
why would you do
that stop
stop i demand you stop
i demand oh hi what in the hell
what
no no
i don't get you
i don't get you and you're teleporting
ass
okay now this time
don't turn around suddenly
how are you over there
you don't make sense
oh hi it's the thing that i
got
staff only
who wants candy
what if i make a distraction here and
then leg it
okay all right that seems to have worked
so now i go this way and then i don't
run smack into the creatures that are
patrolling this area
how about that there's a safe point over
there sure would love to touch
that oh i'd absolutely love to touch
that
but alas i cannot touch that
why can i not touch that i don't know
hey look an old poster
that i already collected
[Music]
all right i'll stop complaining i'm just
gonna get good is that actually an exit
is that actually an exit or are you just
joking
exit
whoa of course oh hey hey hey no no no
no no no no you don't see a thing you
don't see anything
you guys do not see anything
okay
all right now the question is where am i
going there's an exit but i bet i can't
go through that just like i couldn't go
through the other okay that's what why
what do you mean
you don't see anything
no one sees anything
nothing's happening
why would anybody be worried i popped in
this bin therefore i don't cease to
exist
where are you
i guess i was like two feet away from
his face so the fact that he didn't see
me sooner is probably more surprising
than anything
okay let me just look at the hang on let
me look at the map
where
am i
i'm nowhere apparently here no there no
hey
nowhere i am nowhere
all right good
what do i do where do i go
i'm right there i know i'm behind there
so there's an exit here but i don't
think that's anything
at least i don't i don't know maybe it
is
okay
that's my chance of oh god he's gonna
get me
oh god don't hurry up
okay i'm gonna go through here i don't
know why but i'm gonna go through here
oh my god
oh my
god oh
what am i doing why am i doing it what
am i doing and why am i doing it
security door
nope oh god
oh oh why
okay that's a problem oh my god i'm in
the dead end
i went the one way i couldn't go
[Music]
no no no
no
you don't know you don't don't don't
don't don't don't don't do not do not
you won't you won't you didn't you don't
okay
all right well that was useless why
would i have gone that way
is there anything
you are now looking at the exit to this
level
can't see it let me zoom for you
it's in between these two washing
machines from another angle i can show
you that the exit is pretty clear as
it's just a gap in between the washing
machines through that gap is a door that
leads out of this area and progresses
you to the next zone
i did not find this for 45 minutes i am
showing you this because it will help
you understand my slow dissented madness
as i desperately search for a way out of
this place
when it was in fact
right in front of me all along
i am an idiot and i have no
justification for my actions i am merely
showing this to you so you further
understand just how stupid i am
please enjoy
like there's really nothing here i don't
have a level three am i not supposed to
be where i am right now
no i must be supposed to be here
right okay i'm over here can't go in
there
that's okay there's nothing over here hi
friend
okay
there's nothing down there
there's nothing anywhere here i'm gonna
hide in here
i don't know why i can't see what i'm
doing so i don't know if this helped me
at all it did not okay
okay
sure
i don't know once again
i'm going through here but why
okay well all right oh boy
i'm just gonna gun it i'm just gonna gun
no you didn't see nothing
no
there's no way that you would have known
that i got in here i think i just went
the wrong way what i think i think i was
probably supposed to backtrack right i
was supposed to go back maybe i don't
know i don't know where i'm going
there's no real clear directions wait
there's purple there what does that mean
i don't know why the purple is glowing
there oh my god everything is level
three
what was even the point of giving a
level two
what was even the point
oh well i'm dead
oh whoops oh well oops
okay
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy
no thank you
no thank you no no no
no no no no no
oh no no no thank you
my friendly security
oh my god i hate that okay whatever bye
you're going the wrong way stupid
can you not please appear oh you did the
thing
the teleportation i could do without
oh what the hell am where am i
fizzy fazz freddie
what is this
where did i just end up
oh okay
oh it's the other side of
well i guess i'll save again
but i no i can't get back this way
because it i fell down a vent
oh my god
oh come on
there's nothing over there there am i
dumb am i dumb am i dumb yes
yes i am
there's nothing there
there's nothing
there's nothing there why is it telling
me to go that way
why are you telling me to go that way
when there's nothing there
why
why are you telling me to go that way
when there's nothing there
oh god
oh wow you are quick wait no hold on
hold on a second wait hold on
hold on this is this is expressly unfair
this is incredibly unfair what are you
do why are you doing it why are you
doing it
stop doing it
how is this
oh my god and then hyper speed chica
it's hyper speed chica
what
there's no hiding places
i'm looking there is no
hide place
what
it's very clear
that i need to go this way it's telling
me there's a light and everything and
the door actually opens so of course
i'm supposed to go this way
however
what i do after that
who knows
oh my god or you can run or okay oh
my god
oh
so the door doesn't door i'm fine
everyone i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i'm
fine i got hyper speed chica here i'm
fine
i'm fine
i'm trying so desperately to figure out
where wants me to go
but there's really nothing
that's the thing there's really nothing
here
like what's my mission
isn't it just return to freddy
how do i do that
i really want to do that don't
don't
like i really
really
really want to get back to freddy that's
the whoa okay well all right well i
guess i'm dead okay yeah okay
get get
let me go let me go
my friendly security staff can help
friendly you can shut up
oh whoops these two are having a little
bit of a
private moment over there don't
shut up go away wait okay compactor
instructions why do i have compactor
instructions okay is that what i'm
supposed to do i thought that there
might have been something about that
trash compactor is that what i'm
supposed to do and i'm not supposed to
go this way
because that would make a lot of sense
because i can't go this way
so it says something about priming
something and i know that there's more
than just the hanging button
it said something about following the
cables
what did you mean wait no come back here
hello
fill the garbage compactor prime the
compactor engine by pushing the button
in the safe kitchen storage room follow
the cable kitchen storage room
kitchen
storage room
okay
kitchen storage room
okay there must be a kitchen storage
room follow the cable
i don't see a cable
i see this hanging cable
follow
the cable cable
cable cable cable follow the cable
cable
i can't go in there
well i found another collectible so
that's good
star shirt
gray
i
have
no
idea
i have no idea
i have zero idea
what i'm supposed to do
or why i'm supposed to do it
there's no follow-up instruction there's
no
like message that i could read back to
know what i missed
there's nothing it's just all i remember
is freddie going
come back to me my child
and chica is just straight up broken
which i don't mind honestly it's totally
fine
don't look at me i'm not in there
unless like there's like is the mission
someone's laundry
has
a card in their pants and i have to find
that pants
is that the mission
oh oh oh oh oh my god
wha
what
no
no god no god no no
oh hi
please save me for myself
please save me for myself it was right
there oh my god oh my god
oh my god how did i not cheat am i
look at all oh my god i'm stuck how
oh
i'm trapped
you're
gregory
yeah i know your name you're in big
trouble this is not the night to be
wasting my time
so
you are going to wait right there and
lost and found until your parents or the
police arrive
how did i not see
how did i not see that
how
how did i not see the open doorway that
was so clearly there how i walked past
it so many times what is happening i am
losing my mind
i'm losing my mind
i'm on me
i
i haven't saved
[Music]
where am i
look at all this oh at least i'm here
freddy
freddy are you there thank you everybody
so much for
watching that you think you're real
clever hope you enjoyed this video of me
losing my sanity doing something that
should have taken me five minutes
hey
want a funny podcast
click the goddamn link in the
description go check out my podcast with
my good buddies bob and wade
or i'm gonna find you
thank you everybody so much for watching
want some good comfortable clothing
go to cloakbrand.com
looking for more episodes soon
thank you
for watching
i'm gonna die again
all right goodbye everybody
and as always i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
you